What if I told you that two women whom
you might have never heard of before had
found a way to infiltrate the United
Nations and inspire its leaders to
influence the entire world? That
includes you to eventually accept a new
world order. We found handwritten
letters, radio recordings This is Mrs.
Paxton D. Roosevelt speaking from New
York
within the United Nations building. And
libraries next to the UN offices that
all prove this point. Let's dive in.
Helena Blavatsky,
Alice A. Bailey, you guys familiar with
them?
Uh
Henry Alcott, yeah.
Oh, that's another one? Yeah, he's
another one in that group. Okay. So,
they are heavily involved with
theosophy, occultism
and uh Blavatsky, Alice A. Bailey,
they're involved with the Theosophical
Society.
Oh, yeah.
And basically what this comes down to is
worshiper of Lucifer, right? So, I'm
going to show you guys how these
individuals, these two ladies, actually
also influenced United Nations with
these occultist ideas
and how they're even continuing to
influence them today. All right. So,
You'll do say it with a Russian accent.
Helena Petrovna Blavatsky.
That's a good attempt. I tried.
Uh she lived from 1831 to 1890
one and she was a Russian occultist and
theosophist. She traveled to Egypt,
India, and Tibet where she claimed to
have studied ancient spiritual
traditions and mystical
practices. So, she was she was really
into this kind of stuff, right? Like
this wasn't just uh
you know, a a a hobby. This was her
lifestyle.
Now, let's take a look at her writings
and see what she actually believed. So,
she says, "Lucifer, the light bearer,
strange and mysterious name to give to
the
uh capital S spirit of darkness.
Lucifer, the capital S son of the
morning, is it he who bears the light
and with its splendors intolerable
blinds feeble, sensual, or selfish
selfish souls? Doubt it not." Let's look
at another one. "It is but natural, on
the one hand, to view Satan, the serpent
of Genesis, as the real creator and
benefactor, the father of spiritual
mankind, for it is he who was the
harbinger of light, bright, radiant
Lucifer who opened the eyes of the
automaton created by Jehovah, as
alleged, and he who was the first to
whisper, 'In the day you eat thereof,
you shall be as Elohim.' Elohim is just
a plural word. I believe it's Hebrew
actually for gods, knowing good and
evil, can only be regarded in the light
of a savior, an adversary to Jehovah,
the impersonating spirit. He still
remains in esoteric truth the
ever-loving messenger, the angel, the
seraphim and cherubim who both knew and
loved." And then the last one here, "And
now it stands proven that Satan, or the
red fiery dragon, the lord of phosphorus
and Lucifer, or light bearer, is in us.
It is our mind, our tempter and
redeemer, our intelligent liberator and
savior from pure animalism."
It's pretty fascinating that she uses
the term red fiery dragon. Like where
does she get that?
Revelation 12:9.
that's the only other place that that
correlation is made that I'm aware of.
And uh yeah, she's a very polarizing
figure and
uh in another place in that book, The
Secret Doctrine, um she says that
Lucifer was older and higher than
Jehovah and had to be sacrificed to the
new dogma.
So, there you go. Yeah. And we can read
from this previous quote as well that
she was a a gnostic, really. Oh, yeah,
very much so. I mean, she's clearly
saying Lucifer, he's not bad. He's the
one who gave us gnosis. He gave us the
light.
Uh she's even insinuating that he's the
creator.
Because when it says automaton created
by Jehovah, as alleged. In other words,
did God really make you? Nah.
That's what people say. Yeah. Mhm.
Yeah.
There there are some statements too
where she says, yeah, Jesus and she she
makes differ she differs between the
historical Jesus, which she says is just
a man who once was and he's not God, and
the Christ who really is more of a
mystical
mystic kind of Christ, not the kind of
Christ that we see from the Bible. So,
when you read from her and Alice A.
Bailey talk about Christ, it's not Jesus
that we believe in as Christians.
So, she she started the Theosophical
Society. So, it's it's supposed to be
like this philosophy, like this
lifestyle, this idea that you do. So,
interesting that we obviously see the
snake in there.
Well, there's the ouroboros. Yes.
There's the ankh. Mhm. There is the
swastika, which is older than Nazi
Germany. It's a Hindu symbol. There's
also the the Hindu one at the top and I
forget which one that way that one is,
but you see it in all kinds of like new
age restaurants and stuff. Mhm. Um yeah,
and then the ouroboros. Yes, the snake.
of David, which I think people call
um something else as well. It's not
not a pentagram, but it's six-pointed
star.
of Bethlehem is what they call it.
Yeah, it's got all kinds of names, I
think. It but I think it's older than
than David. Yeah, yeah. Is this the
snake that is supposed to be eating its
own tail? Yeah. Yeah, that's the
ouroboros. Yeah. Oh, that's what it's
called. Okay. Yeah.
So, that's their logo. So, I think it's
pretty fitting that this gentleman right
here, Dr. Per Faxneld, he is a professor
at Stockholm University who studies
occultism, that he actually calls it a
satanic uh
um
philosophy or movement, so to speak.
He says that is Helena Blavatsky's
influence, The Secret Doctrine, one of
the foundation texts of theosophy,
contains chapters propagating an
unembarrassed Satanism. Theosophical
sympathy for the devil also extended to
the name of their journal Lucifer
and discussions conducted in it. To
Blavatsky, Satan is a cultural hero akin
to Prometheus. According to her
reinterpretation of the Christian myth
of the fall in Genesis 3, Satan in the
shape of the serpent brings gnosis and
liberates mankind. So, he nails the hits
the nail on the head that this really is
is a gnostic kind of teaching. And then
here he also says, "As Stephen Prothero,
among others, has shown, theosophy
originated in spiritualism." Very much
so. Yeah.
Yep.
So, what does theosophy
mean? Like theo is God, right? But
what's
the other half of the word?
Um
sophy would be
um of Greek origin and it would be like
um the word for like sophia,
uh which is wisdom, if I remember right,
in Greek. So, theo God, sophy wisdom,
probably. I mean, in this context it
would somewhat make sense when the devil
said, you know, if you eat the fruit,
you'll be like gods knowing good and
evil, which is the wisdom, I guess.
I was right.
Discernment. Yeah, it's basically wise
God. Theo, that comes from theos and
sophos, which is God and wise. So, Yeah.
Yeah. Except that obviously they worship
a different kind of God. They worship
the God of this earth, which is Satan,
which they see as, oh, he's the the
light bearer, the light bringer, the one
that gives us gnosis, enlightenment, and
it's a good thing. Yeah, you saw in
their logo it said um there is no
religion higher than truth. So, for
them, knowledge, whatever the knowledge
is, is truth and therefore that's
religion, just just knowing.
Which is very fascinating, you know,
from a philosophical standpoint.
I don't know exactly how to phrase this,
but
you know,
for example, God
there were things he never wanted
humanity to know. Mhm.
There was knowledge that we were never
meant to partake of. Yeah. Mhm. And in
some ways, you could also you could look
at, you know, the devil pointing the
finger at God and being like, "You're
you're practicing censorship." Mhm.
Well, you know, some people they're
they're, you know, I'm pretty
libertarian when it comes to stuff like
that.
But at the same time, you look at God's
kingdom and God's like,
"Yeah, I believe in censorship. I
believe in you not seeing or knowing
anything about evil." Mhm. And and you
know, I have to I have to look at God's
perspective and say, "Yeah, you know, I
kind of agree with that because there
are things, even as libertarian as we
want to get, there are things that we
would say probably we appreciate being
censored." Like you don't want
everywhere, you know? You don't want
people to just be taking their clothes
off and walking down the street. Like
there is some form of censorship I think
as
a society or as individuals we find
acceptable. Mhm. Of course, we want
people to have free speech and be able
to speak their mind and and things like
that. But and God allowed Satan to
speak,
you know? He could have just
squashed him and shut him up. But
ultimately,
God never wanted that to be known. He
allowed for the possibility, but he
never really wanted humanity to go that
way. Like I don't want you to know all
the evil and dark stuff. Mhm.
So, Yeah. So, it's it's the same as as
you have kids. Would you want your kids
to know evil? No. If you had the option,
I don't.
you you would rather because knowing is
also experiencing.
Like you have to experience suffering
and evil if you know about it. But so I
think it's a fair thing for God to want
to censor that. Yeah.
Because it's loving to censor you to not
know evil.
Yeah, shielding you from what God knows
is ultimately going to harm you and and
cause death and destruction and pain and
and all of that. So Yeah. And the devil
was really smart with presenting it to
because he went to even said you'll be
like God's knowing uh good and evil.
Right? It's the knowledge of well, they
already knew what was good. And because
they lived
Yeah, he wasn't offering much in that
regard, was he?
So it's like it'll be it'll be like
God's knowing evil. So the whole offer
there was like do you want to know the
bad stuff?
sell your house my your house to you.
You know, it's like you already have it.
Like Yeah. Mhm.
So
Blavatsky also talks about uh well, you
know, she's one of the co-founders of
Theosophy of the Theosophical Society
and she actually talks about in the key
of Theosophy what their three objectives
are. Now, I won't read all three of
them, but the top one is interesting.
She says the first object of the society
is to form the nucleus of a universal
brotherhood on of humanity without
distinction of race, creed, caste, or
color. And if you look at this next one,
she says in Lucifer volume 3,
Theosophy is religion
and the society it's one universal
church. Thus, Theosophy is not a
religion we say, but religion itself.
The one bond of unity which is so
universal and all embracing that no man
as no speck from gods and mortal down to
animals, the blade of grass and atom can
be outside of its light. Therefore, any
organization or body of that name must
necessarily be a universal brotherhood.
So therefore
any organization or body of that name
what name? Of religion. If you are in a
religion or a religious person,
you cannot be but in a universal
brotherhood is what she's saying.
Whether you're a
a mortal, whether you are a god, or
whether you are an animal. They want
unity among everybody under one
religion. Yeah. Do you remember watching
the trailer for the Wicked movie?
I've seen it. Mhm. You know that was uh
one of the points in the in the trailer.
The goat, he's like you don't know the
whole truth, you know, and Oz was down
on the animals. Like he was
um trying to restrict their rights or
remove them from public or whatever.
It's like, no, no, we want the animals
to be like equal.
It was kind of interesting. It just kind
of reminded me of that. Yeah.
Gods down to animals. And Wicked is also
full on a cult and witchcraft.
But if you're going to teach, you know,
evolution, you you really do elevate
the
um that part of God's creation, you
know, animals to be pretty much on equal
footing with human beings. Mhm. So we
can see this this idea of unity among
all people here.
And especially let's unite them all
under one religion. Well, we have to ask
the question of course and we know the
answer that. What religion is that and
what does it constitute and who is the
god that you worship? We already know
who they worship and we so we already
know what kind of religion she is
foreseeing everybody to be under. Now
this is where things get really
interesting and why we dive into the
idea of how they're infiltrating the
United Nations with these satanic ideas.
This is directly off of Theosophical
World Resource Center website and it
says it's a center was established in
1928 by Margaret Cousins with the
assistance of the European Federation
of the Theosophical Society. The center
maintained contact with international
movements based in Geneva.
The League of Nations had its
headquarters in Geneva and it was hoped
that the Theosophical influence would
reach the work of the League.
The League of Nations is the precursor
to the United Nations. Right. They just
changed the name later on.
But it's the same thing.
Mhm. And they're literally and and right
now the headquarters of the UN is in New
York City.
But the headquarters of the European
branch of the UN is in Geneva,
Switzerland. Mhm. The League of Nations
headquarters were also in Geneva,
Switzerland and they were like, let's
establish a
um headquarters own headquarters right
there or center there so we can that the
Theosophical influence would reach the
work of the League. Yeah, they wanted to
lobby. Yeah.
They wanted to put in their own ideas.
Which again are satanic. So
this to me was mind-blowing.
This right here
is a website of the United Nations.
United Nations Geneva, you see it on the
left. It says Theosophical League for
the Federation of Nations, Mrs. Sharp,
Secretary of the Theosophical League for
the Federation of Nations, applies for
affiliation to the League on behalf of
the Theosophical League for the
Federation of Nations. These right here
are handwritten letters that the
Theosophical League for the Federation
of Nations wrote to the League of
Nations and said, "Hey, look,
we want to be affiliated with you guys.
We want to work together with you guys
and how can we make this happen?" This
is on the website of the United Nations.
Uh I must say Theosophical League for
the Federation of Nations is not the
same as the Theosophical Society. It's a
different organizations, but they are
affiliated and they are uh I mean they
have the exact same
uh philosophy, basically.
So here is a letter right here. You see
at the top Theosophical League for the
Federation of Nations applies for
affiliation to the League on behalf of
the Theosophical League for the
Federation of Nations formed at an
international congress in Vienna on July
27th, 1923.
So it's right there. It's right there in
front of us. It has been scanned in by
the United Nations for everyone to see.
And then this is the the person from the
Theosophical League for the Federation
of Nations that writes this to the
League of Nations, again the precursor
to the United Nations. It says, "It
encourages us to know that you are
interested in our Theosophical League
for the Federation of Nations." Okay? So
they're saying thank you for being
interested in us.
"We are determined to become a real
influence in the world of affairs
including politics
Yep. as a large part of our purpose is
to support the League of Nations."
Here you see that it's the chairman and
secretary
that signed this off, Theosophical
League for the Federation of Nations.
And here is a response letter from the
League of Nations. And here it says, "We
regret exceedingly not having seen it
before." Referring to the letter
that they wrote to the League of
Nations, "as we believe that the
Theosophical League for the Federation
of Nations and the League of Nations
could be of use to each other."
What do you guys think about that?
I don't know what they would find
useful.
So yeah. Yeah.
Seems uh seems polite, but I'm like,
what are you thinking?
Yeah, I mean
honestly, if you don't have or don't
want anything to do with it. Like you
are familiar with what they want. You're
familiar with, okay, so they hold to the
writings of Blavatsky and the writings
of Alice A. Bailey
and you know that they worship Lucifer
and you're like, oh yikes, that is
pretty wild. You politely be like,
sorry, but no, thank you. I don't think
You know, you would say it up front. You
not just be like, I'm so sorry. I just
regret so exceedingly not having seen it
before.
Because we can both work together and
we've got something in store for each
other.
Now here they say, "There is no doubt in
my mind that we are both working for the
brotherhood of nations. You are perhaps
working more spiritually and the League
of Nations being so to say a method of
government is working more practically,
but the aims of both is to destroy
causes of friction and we both know that
in order to do so we must have a
collective feeling and a collective
will."
So again, they're totally agreeing with
each other and they're just like We got
to work together. We got to work
together, you know, like
it's it's almost like uh this is the end
goal. We want unity in the world and
however we're going to get it, uh you
worship Lucifer and we have got the
satanic stuff. Yeah, come on board with
us. Well, we'll work with you, too. And
here is the last part of the letter. "I
am requested to say that the
Secretary-General
is much gratified to learn that the
Theosophical League is deeply interested
in the League of Nations and that its
members are enthusiastic supporters of
the principles on which it is founded."
So again,
if you knew that what they believe and
you don't agree with it, this is not
something you're going to tell them.
Yeah, and the Theosophical Society was
never shy to
um
you know, put their support behind
different individuals or
um
yeah, or or make it known what they
thought, you know, for example like
William Crookes in 1800s when he was
doing work in crim- chemistry,
they were like, we think, you know, what
he's doing is ancient wisdom, you know,
you can find that on the Theosophical uh
wiki. There was another man, very
polarizing type figure. Emanuel
Swedenborg is probably one of the most
educated men in Europe at the time.
And they said that he was probably
did the most for
helping promote, I think it was the
beliefs of anybody um in his time. I
mean, they don't they're not shy about
saying, "We agree with this person and
what they're doing. We agree with this
person and what they're doing, and we
think it's great." So. Yeah, it's um
it almost seems like they have an
agenda,
the Theosophical Society, and they're
like, "We're going to get it done,
and we're going to use whoever will take
the bait, so to speak."
And looks like you went and took the
bait. Okay, so this is the Theosophical
Theosophy Wiki website, where as you can
see, they're making a connection between
Blavatsky and the United Nations. So,
this is their own writings. Like,
they're talking about this themselves.
And this is what they say.
"The Theosophical Society, dedicated
from its inception to the ideal of
brotherhood, has been called the first
United Nations, comprising as it does
within its membership individuals of
many nations, many cultural and ethnic
backgrounds. If we, who are its members
today, building out of all differences
and distinctions a unique harmony of
purpose, remain loyal to the visions
toward which Blavatsky pointed, it may
be our privilege to portray the pattern
of a truly universal brotherhood of
humanity founded on the spiritual
perception of man's essential nature. No
higher privilege could come to any group
of men and women, but the price of
brotherhood is paid with the currency of
present action, not the promise
promissory notes of tomorrow's good
intentions." They're saying themselves,
"We were actually the first United
Nations. We
They're not saying we are the United
Nations, but they're saying what the
United Nations is doing, yeah, we were
doing that already." It's almost like
they they based it off of us. Yeah, kind
of. And it's interesting for me that
they're saying that themselves, having
so much influence in the United Nations
as all
uh show you later on. So, Alice Ann
Bailey, uh also known as Alice A.
Bailey,
she was a British immigrant to the
United States. She was a follower of
Blavatsky. She was born like in the
later years that Blavatsky died. Mhm.
She was one of the most influential
people in Theosophy and the New Age. At
age 15, she claimed to have been visited
by a spiritual being, the master K. H.
or Kuthumi, who inspired her lifelong
commitment to spiritual work. Now, I'm
really questioning who this Kuthumi
actually is that is visiting her, and
could it perhaps be a demon?
Uh she joined the Theosophical Society
in 1917 after she had moved to the
United States. So, do you guys think
that Alice A. Bailey was also a big
promoter of the unification of all
religions? More than likely. More than
likely.
was, then she would. Yeah, absolutely.
Yes. The externalization of the
hierarchy, page 169, reads, "The day is
dawning when all religions will be
regarded as emanating from one great
spiritual source. All will be seen as
unitedly providing the one root out of
which the universal world religion See,
it's See, they're even saying universal
world religion will inevitably emerge.
Then there will be neither Christian
nor heathen, neither Jew nor Gentile,
but simply one great body of believers
gathered out of all the current
religions."
But believers in what? Yeah, exactly.
It's a good question. Yeah. It's not
Christians, Jews,
you know, Hindu.
What's what's left? Believers in what?
Yeah. Well, what does she believe in?
Right? Does Does Does she Does she If
she's a follower of Blavatsky and
There's no time to go into all of her
quotes. Right. But she is another
follower of Lucifer. She sees him as the
light bearer. She sees him as angel of
light. You know, all those things that
Blavatsky believes in as well. So, uh
she founded the Lucis Trust.
Now, Keys, I'm sure you know what the
original name of Lucis Trust was.
The Lucifer Trust.
The Lucifer Trust. I kid you not, Holly.
It was called the Lucifer Trust. Well,
it's not too different from Lucis. Yeah.
At this point.
Yeah, but then they're like, "Oh, well,
people are complaining about, you know,
it's too satanic, so we'll change it to
Lucis Trust and have a bit of a
cover-up."
So, the Lucis Trust promotes recognition
and practice of spiritual principles.
You can see that right here.
And
um this to me is mind-blowing. I saw
this video years ago when I first became
a Christian.
I'm not going to say anything. Just
watch this, and I think you'll be
mind-blown.
Over here, you have
the library of Alice A. Bailey.
And if you see, she has numerous volumes
here on the New Age movement
and spiritualism.
This is right here
in the Lucis Trust uh
library located in London,
directly
next to uh
the United Nations center as well.
And this is inside of the Lucis Trust
library.
You have a book here on William
Shakespeare, William Shakespeare's
writings.
This is in
Lucis Trust library.
So,
what do you think William Shakespeare's
writings are all about?
Huh.
Here's another interesting one.
Inside of the library of Lucis Trust.
The Candid History of the Jesuits.
Clearly showing the link between
the Jesuits and spiritualism.
Here's another book right here.
The Yoga.
Teachings on Yoga.
All of these
ideologies are in harmony
with the Theosophical movement. They're
all in harmony with spiritualism.
See multiple books here on Yoga.
Karma Yoga.
Here's another one.
Yogi Philosophy.
Look at this.
Gnostic Gospels.
Here's where you get your Easter from.
Mhm.
Let me see.
You have the Rosicrucian manual right
here.
And this is in the This is Blavatsky.
Now, yeah.
Let me see.
Now, that you have up here Blavatsky's
writings on
Secret Doctrine, Madame Blavatsky.
I mean, this is it.
This is where
This is where it's all at. But you can
just imagine
how many fallen angels
have to be in this place itself.
Because
these
are ideologies that they themselves
conceived.
So, I I looked up how you can donate to
Lucis Trust. So, you have to actually
fill out a form and say,
"These are the books I want to donate."
And they have to approve it. So, it's
not like you can just
give them any book.
Can't give them a Bible. You can't give
them a Bible. They're not going to
accept that.
And
um he put actually I cut this out of the
video cuz it was too long, but he put in
there in the beginning of the video
which building it is. So, if anybody
wants to check it out for themselves to
see if this is true, it's in London,
Whitehall building number six. Just walk
right in. Yeah, just walk right in.
Right next to the to the United Nations.
Right next to the United Nations. So,
Lucis Trust, that was founded by Alice
A. Bailey,
uh and yeah, they're inside the UN
building, or at least right next to it,
on purpose.
Now, um they say that they want to
support the United Nations. Uh and they
do that with this organization called
World Goodwill.
You can see right here, the Lucis Trust
has consultative status with the
Economic and Social Council of the
United Nations. and World Goodwill is
recognized by the Department of Global
Communications at the United Nations as
a non-governmental organization or NGO.
NGOs are organizations that are hugely
influential
to the UN.
And in fact, the UN wanted to work with
different NGOs to promote their work of
what they're doing. And it's almost like
it's almost like reverse lobbying. Like
the NGOs are saying, "Well, we want this
in in to and these principles to
influence the United Nations." The
United Nations like, "Yes, but we want
to make sure that we can do our work,
too. So, how can you promote our work?"
It's like they're working together.
Mhm. So, is Goodwill an NGO? Yeah, World
Goodwill.
Goodwill? World Goodwill
is a an NGO recognized by the UN.
Okay.
They're like in their registry,
basically. So, you have to apply and the
UN says, "Yes." Right. Right. So, again,
what is World Goodwill? What do they
want to do? They say it themselves, to
cooperate in the world of preparation
for the reappearance of the Christ.
But what Christ are they talking about?
We read in Blavatsky's writings there
are two different Christs. There is the
historical Christ,
and then there is the mythic or cosmic
Christ or um this
divine being
that they're talking about that is that
they're looking forward to reappearing.
And so, in the Bible, it does talk about
that Satan will come as an angel of
light. He will come back to Earth
pretending to be Jesus. When I believe
it's in Matthew 24, where it says,
"If you hear anybody say anything about
here's the Christ, don't go looking for
him. Don't go." Right? But the Gnostics
or occultists or whatever they are, the
theosophists,
they're like, "Yeah, we're looking
forward to a Christ." Mhm. But on whose
side are they?
And who are they trying to prepare the
world for? It's a good question.
Okay, so she says, Alice A. Bailey,
Discipleship in the New Age, um volume
11. She says, "Within the United Nations
is the germ and seed of a great
international and meditating reflective
group, a group of thinking and informed
men and women in whose hands lies the
destiny of humanity. This is largely
under the control of many fourth-rate
disciples, if you could but realize it.
And their point of meditative focus is
the intuitional
or Buddhic plane, the plane upon which
all hierarchical activity is today to be
found." So, she's like, "Yeah, the
United Nations, yeah, we we got our
people there." Mhm. Like, we're we're
getting the work done. "Evidence of the
growth of the human intellect along the
needed receptive lines for the
preparation of the new age can be seen
in the planning of various nations and
in the efforts of the United Nations to
formulate a world plan. From the very
start of this unfoldment, three occult
factors have governed the development of
all these plans." Now, she never
actually goes into what these these
plans are,
but it's interesting that she's like,
"Yeah, so from the beginning of the
United Nations, from the very start of
it,
there's been some occult factors that
have governed the development of the
plans of the UN."
I mean, why would she say that unless
unless perhaps it is true? Oh, she
believes it, anyway. She believes it,
yes.
Um and and again, they're trying to
influence the UN. They're clearly having
something to do with the UN. They're
clearly having something at stake that
they're like, "This is worth investing
in."
And clearly it's working, because
otherwise, if they wouldn't Why else
would they have an NGO recognized by the
UN that's lobbying for them if it's not
working?
Now, let's look at another individual
who was inspired by Alice A. Bailey.
This is Robert Muller. He was the
Secretary General of the United Nations
who was heavily influenced by theosophy,
Alice A. Bailey,
and also a well-known Jesuit, which
we'll look at in just a second.
He was part of the UN from the beginning
stages. He worked there for about 40
years, and he worked his way up. So,
this is not a small name. This is a big
guy who was there from the beginning.
There's a preface for the World Core
Curriculum Manual, which he wrote. The
preface for his
manual says, "The underlying philosophy
upon which the Robert Muller School is
based will be found in the teaching set
forth in the books of Alice A. Bailey by
the Tibetan teacher Djwhal Khul,
published by Lucis Publishing Company,
and the teachings of M. Morya as given
in the Agni Yoga series books." Okay, so
he is saying, "Yeah, so I started a
school, and uh from my understanding,
this is where you he teaches some of
these spiritualistic
New Agey aspects.
And he's like, "My school is based in
the in in the teachings set forth in the
books of Alice A. Bailey and by Djwhal
Khul."
This guy was the Secretary General of
the United Nations.
So,
do we think that at any point
he did not use some of his ideologies in
his work at the UN? No, they're clearly
partners. Yeah, 100%. I mean, probably
even before he he got in there. Right.
had people
preparing the way. Yeah.
Why would he not do the same thing if
this is his belief system?
Right.
So, he also says, this is interesting,
"We must work as quickly as possible to
a one world government, a one world
religion under a one world leader."
And and if you understand where prophecy
is going, you understand Revelation 13,
this is where it's going to end up.
Yeah.
It would be fascinating to know who they
want that to be. Who's the what What's
the religion and who's the leader?
Uh-huh. It's It's interesting. I'm just
throwing this out there. Though he was
into Alice A. Bailey and into the New
Age, he would also consider himself
Catholic.
Oh, fascinating. Although although Alice
A. Bailey did say no Christians would
be, you know, left.
Yeah. Yeah. So, then I would encourage
anybody to look up the origins of of
Catholicism. Uh link in the description
for a really good documentary,
Revelation the Bride, the Beast, and
Babylon. You can look it up for
yourself. Okay, so here he also uh
co-authored or co-edited a book in honor
of Teilhard de Chardin, who was a
Jesuit. And Teilhard de Chardin, in
fact, also believed in very much the
same teachings of new He was super New
Agey and all this kind of things, even
though he was a Catholic. He was very
much into the same beliefs of let's go
toward a one world religion. And here
you can see for yourself, he's on the
website of the Jesuits, and he was very
much uh involved in the Society of
Jesus.
And in fact, if you watch many of our
videos, you will know that the Jesuits
are a secret society that unfortunately
is put in place to destroy the
Protestant movement and turn people back
to Catholicism. But they are secret
society, and you can look it up for
yourself. We'll put a video in the
description as well. So, um Robert
Muller writes about Teilhard. "Teilhard
had always viewed the United Nations as
the progressive institutional embodiment
of his philosophy." And he also says,
"Teilhard de Chardin influenced his
companion Father de Breuvery, who
inspired his colleagues who started a
rich process of global and long-term
thinking in the UN, which affected many
nations around the world. I have myself
been deeply influenced by Teilhard."
So, here you see Teilhard de Chardin, a
Jesuit, who was heavily involved in in
New Age and occultism, who was in a
secret society, who believed in a one
world religion that we need to go
towards, who heavily influenced Robert
Muller, who was the Secretary General of
the United Nations.
I mean, come on.
So, this is the a clip from the American
Teilhard Association annual meeting at
the Union Theological Seminary
in New York City, and there's a lecture
called Ilia Delio, and she says what
Teilhard was actually about.
So, this is what Teilhard says. "The
kind of religion we seek cannot be found
in the religious traditions of the past,
which are linked to static categories."
He says, "We need a new religion full of
dynamism and conquest, a religion that
can utilize the free energy of the Earth
to build us into a greater wow, unity."
So, again,
what what does he want? He wants unity.
One world religion.
One world religion. Let's get everybody
together.
the energy or do stuff that apparently
other religions aren't doing or like
Yeah, you know, it's the thing is, it's
so
the ideas can be so close to what we
understand in Christianity.
Jesus' prayer in John, chapter 17, was
about unity. In the same chapter,
though, he says, "Sanctify them by your
truth. Your word is truth." So, Jesus is
also defining the
common ground or or just the ground on
which that unity is founded, and it's
not just on
"Oh, let's all get together and form a
religion on whatever, from whatever
background, and you know,
and and we need unity." We unity around
what, you know? It's like when we had
the Civil War in the United States, the
South was united,
the North was united, but they weren't
together, you know, they they recognized
there were differences even though they
each had a unity
separate from one another. Of course,
now we are the
you know, we're we're more well
I don't know, maybe we're not as
harmonious anymore as we
as
as we we thought we were in years past,
but
are the United States.
the United States, yeah. And so
Yeah.
Yeah, that's why I I don't believe in
the ecumenical ideas because
ecumenism is really asking you to set
aside what you believe for the sake of
one belief.
You know, ecumenism doesn't work if
everybody is doing their own thing. You
have to come together
and you have to believe
one doctrine under one God under one
um
yeah, one system.
And
if
there's going to be one that's going to
rise to the top. One existing system
already is going to rise to the top or
you just merge it all together. A little
bit from here, a little bit from there,
a little bit there.
But it's like
it what what about your own personal
convictions and your own walk with God
where you say, I have studied genuinely
studied scriptures for myself. I believe
this is the truth.
Mhm. And now all of a sudden you have to
set your own
conscience aside and what you believe
for the sake of unity.
And I don't think that's what God wants
from us. He wants us to have unity
within the truth. Right. And
it's like it's the same reason as the
Bible says
dark and light cannot mix or don't marry
an unbeliever. It's like if you have
a Methodist and you have a Baptist and
they get married, it causes tension in
the marriage
because you cannot unite having both
standing on your own principles and what
you believe.
So
it's the same idea.
Yeah, I don't know. It's it's it's
really strange. It's kind of akin to
like Babylonian type culture where they
would
pretty much allow for
a lot of different things, but you know,
the king and
the I guess the the country that was
doing the unifying had that had the
influence and the power. They had their
religion and their gods and they
tried to impose that on everybody else
by re-indoctrination
or indoctrination, I guess, of other
cultures.
I don't know, it seems very much akin to
that. But Christianity doesn't it
doesn't work that way.
Christianity is freedom.
Yeah, it's it's it's freedom. It it's
it's not like, well, you know
you know, Chris Yeah, if freedom in that
we can exist among other people, right?
We can have the tolerance and say
if you want to believe this over here,
that's fine. You can believe that over
there.
If you want to believe in in pink
bunnies, great. You know, but I'm over
here and and this is what I believe. And
so we have lines of distinction. Yeah.
But we don't say Christianity is like,
you know what, believe in pink bunnies,
red bunnies, blue bunnies, whatever,
it's okay. Yeah, you know, it's all
Christian. Mhm.
It's not. You know, it doesn't it
doesn't work that way. Jesus said he was
the way, the truth, and the life. Mhm.
No one comes to the Father except by
him. So
it's like one way. It also describes
that way as narrow. It didn't say it was
like a broad path that everybody's
taking. Yeah. So
Yeah, and and obviously eventually there
will be destruction for sin. Like there
are consequences to not choosing God.
And that's a whole other topic that we
don't we can we don't have to talk about
right now.
But
it is the idea of of like you said, like
there's freedom of choice. God has given
us freedom of choice. That's why there's
sin in the first place cuz there's
freedom of choice.
You can choose not to worship God.
Right.
But when you go toward an ecumenical
system or one world religion, there is
no freedom. That's gone. Yep. And there
is no individuality. And as they were
saying, there is no Christianity. Mhm.
So I want to show you guys one more
individual here, Eleanor Roosevelt. She
was at one point the first lady to
President Roosevelt and she was in fact
very much involved with the UN. So here
it says, this is from the un.org, First
Lady of the United States of America
from 1933 to 1945, Eleanor Roosevelt was
appointed in 1946 as a delegate to the
United Nations General Assembly by the
United States President Harry S. Truman.
She served as the first chairperson of
the Commission on Human Rights and
played an instrumental role in drafting
the Universal Declaration of Human
Rights. So that's a big deal, right? She
was the chairperson
of the Commission of Human Rights that
played an instrumental role in drafting
the Universal Declaration of Human
Rights.
At a time of increasing East-West
tensions, Eleanor Roosevelt used her
enormous prestige and credibility with
both superpowers to steer the drafting
process toward its successful
completion. In 1968, she was
posthumously awarded the United Nations
Human Rights Prize.
Was she also into the occult? Yes, she
was. From vice.com, while it's possible
some ladies were better at concealing
their practices, five in particular.
And then they mention all the names and
they also include Roosevelt. They held
moderate interests in the occult. All of
whom claimed to have seen Lincoln's
ghost or felt his presence during their
years in the White House. Though they
weren't bringing in astrologers or using
mediums like others
did. She also brought in a palm reader.
This is Nellie Simmons and it says
Nellie began her study of palmistry as a
science in 1895, reading and taking
impressions of palms for over 40 years.
She developed a system that was based,
she said, on ancient Egyptian principles
that assessed personality and character
based upon the lines of one's palm. She
had the reputation of being a palm
reader to the stars, leading actors,
actresses, and famous people like Leslie
Howard, Helen Hayes Mary Pickford, Walt
Disney, Franklin and Eleanor Roosevelt,
Susan B. Anthony, Joan Crawford, Carole
Lombard, James Whitcomb Riley, Amelia
Earhart, and many others had their palms
read by Nellie. Many of the palm prints
she made were later donated to Library
of Congress.
I think that's really strange already.
It's like, isn't that the the
government's Library of Congress and
there's like
palm prints from a palm reader there?
What what's a palm print? Is like when
they write what they saw on the palm?
Yeah, well, they're yeah, they're
reading
I mean, I'm you you using that term very
loosely, right?
They're reading your palm. So
you know, you go and you show them your
palm and then they're like discerning
Right, but a palm print what like What
did they donate? Probably like a
fingerprint like they know what
they used actual ink and then like had
the picture of it which she used.
have thought everyone's was unique.
They're supposed to be. I'm pretty sure
I mean your fingerprints are unique. So
if it is, I don't know how you can
develop much of a science around that.
That's a good point. I mean, sure
there's going to be patterns and
similarities, but then if there are
patterns and similarities, doesn't kind
of throw things off?
I don't know. Yeah.
The Bible's pretty clear that we're
supposed to avoid this kind of stuff. So
Yeah. Um and so Eleanor Roosevelt, not
unsurprisingly, also was very much
interested in Alice A. Bailey. And in
fact, she in this
radio recording here, she reads The
Great Invocation written by Alice A.
Bailey from the UN building on the Great
Invocation Day. I mean, this is pretty
wild. Great Invocation Day? The There's
There is supposed to be a day called the
Great Invocation Day, which you will
hear in this radio broadcast.
And she's reading The Great Invocation
written by Alice A. Bailey inside the
UN.
Today is World Invocation Day, a day
when millions of people throughout the
world are joining together to say The
Great Invocation, a prayer which belongs
to no group or individual, but to men
and women of goodwill everywhere. The
Sunday editor of The New York Times has
said, "We need, in addition to the
A-bomb and the H-bomb, what I call the
S-bomb, the spiritual bomb."
You are invited to share the meditation
of The Great Invocation as it is
repeated by an outstanding American,
Mrs. Franklin D. Roosevelt.
This is Mrs. Franklin D. Roosevelt
speaking from New York
within the United Nations building.
We are living today in a troubled world.
In many parts of the world
people have a sense of discouragement as
to whether they will ever solve their
difficulties.
And it seems to me that those of us
who feel that a spiritual
leadership is necessary in the world are
looking for ways in which to express
what we feel.
And someone sent me the other day
a
an invocation.
It is called The Great Invocation.
And it seems to me to express the
aspirations held by many people
throughout the world. So I'm going to
read it to you
on this program.
The Great Invocation.
I don't know. I mean, she's it's just
weird.
You wonder
I mean, obviously she has enough
connections that it's
it's like she's she's supportive of
Alice A. Bailey, but you're like
how can you
how can you blend all that together? You
know, I just
I don't understand. Like, clearly if you
look into their beliefs, it's
not Christian. And she was a Christian.
Yeah, that's the other that's the weird
thing about it. It's like, you know, a
lot of people on the list that you just
mentioned, all those ladies would be
considered
Christian. So, I don't know. It's like
you make it makes you wonder, like, are
you just playing politician? Are you
just playing Christian? Are you just,
you know, it's like, what's real with
you?
You know, what's what do you actually
believe?
Mhm. It just makes you wonder. But, I
don't know how you could be that close
to all that stuff and and support it and
read it for people and not be supportive
of it. But, at the same time, I don't
know how you could be Christian, too. I
don't know how you could
it's just so strange. Maybe she could
have used the label Christian to uh
like gain popularity.
She could have. You know, it it in some
in some ways is not surprising.
I have I came across a quote once that
said 1/3 of America by the end of the
1800s
was considered a spiritualist. Mhm.
Which is a huge chunk of the population.
Yeah. And you're like, well, how could
that? You I mean
you know, we always say America's a
Christian nation, less and less so, but
you would think
that long ago it would be way more so,
right?
Mhm. And and it went on to basically
say, well, they didn't dissociate their
spiritualistic beliefs and their
Christian beliefs. They
they basically they claimed to both at
the same time
and and practiced both. Mhm. So, maybe
that's what it is. Like
you're just putting Christianity and
Theosophy in a blender and
you know, and Theosophy doesn't care I
guess. It just seems to like mix it all
up and be like, whatever.
Yeah. I mean, Theosophy's like
if you're a Christian
we'll work on you and you'll come to our
side. Yeah. And then we'll just make one
big religion out of you. Just bizarre.
Yeah.
Yeah, so it's interesting. Um there
there are a lot more interesting uh
facts, connections to the UN and
occultism. I mean, uh if people are
interested, I'll put a link in the
description. Make sure you watch Walter
Veith's whole video on the UN and occult
connections. It's it's in there.
But, I was more pointing out the
connections between Theosophy and Alice
A. Bailey and Blavatsky and the United
Nations.
And and and their push for a one world
religion.
Now
if if it was just like, okay, they they
they're some of these key
and pretty big players in the UN that
are heavily influenced
by Blavatsky and Alice A. Bailey, that's
one thing. But, the fact that they have
an NGO that's still going, right? That's
still heavily lobbying where
the UN needs its NGOs, NGOs need the UN,
and they're working together.
They're having like prayer conferences
at the
uh good world of goodwill or whatever
they call it, world goodwill, and the
Lucis Trust. They're they're having
libraries right next to the UN. I mean,
they're just like pushing it.
And and praying about what? And and like
world unity? And then it's like, well,
to who? And you look at their documents
and it's like, I don't know, you could
say God, that doesn't mean you're
praying to God if in the back of your
mind, you know, you think God is
Lucifer. Yeah.
Yeah, which God are we talking about?
Yes. And And also expecting the return
of Christ, but which Christ are you
talking about?
Yeah. Are you talking about the biblical
Christ? They're not. They're saying it.
They don't believe in a historical
Christ. Are they talking about this
mystical kind of Christ?
And then it's like, well, the Bible
talks about this Satan coming back as an
angel of light. Are you are you
preparing the world for that? Is that
what you're saying? Are you are you
doing that through your work?
So, it's interesting. These things are
all happening. Revelation 13 talks about
that at one point the world will all be
following a one world religion, a one
world system, so to speak. Why do we say
a one world religion? Because Revelation
13 does talk about the act of worship.
And if you do not worship this beast
power, which is all symbolic if you want
to know more about this, please go to
the description or or tap the link at
the top here that will pop up right this
second, and it will it will take you to
a video that talks about what this all
means and what is the Antichrist power
and what is the mark of the beast.
Revelation 13:11-18 says, "Then I saw
another beast coming up out of the
earth, and he had two horns like a lamb
and spoke like a dragon.
And he exercises all the authority of
the first beast in his presence and
causes the earth and those who dwell in
it to worship the first beast, whose
deadly wound was healed. He performs
great signs, so that he even makes fire
come down from heaven on the earth in
the sight of men. And he deceives those
who dwell on the earth by those signs
which he was granted to do in the sight
of the beast, telling those who dwell on
the earth to make an image to the beast
who was wounded by the sword and lived.
He was granted power to give breath to
the image of the beast, that the image
of the beast should both speak and cause
as many as would not worship the image
of the beast to be killed. He causes
all, both small and great, rich and
poor, free and slave to receive a mark
on their right hand or on their
foreheads, and that no one may buy or
sell except one who has the mark of the
name of the beast or the number of his
name. Here is wisdom. Let him who has
understanding calculate the number of
the beast, for it is the number of the
man. His number is 666.
So, we are headed towards this event
happening in the world. Again
a one world kind of system, a one world
kind of order, a one world religion,
where if you do not worship this beast,
we're going heading towards this
time this place in time in the world
where this will happen.
And
that the occultists are like, yeah, we
know, and we're preparing for this. Mhm.
And it's like Satan has his flavors
everywhere to prepare us as a people, as
humanity, for either oh oh, you're an
occultist, I'm going to do it this way.
Oh, but you believe in aliens, we have a
documentary on that, too. I'm going to
do it this way. Oh, but you're a
Christian, I'm going to do it this way.
Like, whatever your flavor is, I will
prepare you for that unless you are
grounded in the scriptures and have a
genuine relationship with Jesus.
Even seeking to understand this prophecy
that you know what's coming and that we
know that the only way we are going to
not fall for this trap is when we are
safe in Jesus. Yeah. And it's
Yeah, you see it with the whole UN
stuff. It's like it it's the
governmental like organization
partnering with a religious organization
to bring about
the one world system. I find interesting
that
that the guy, the uh Secretary-General
of the United Nations, Robert Mueller
was in fact also heavily inspired by a
Jesuit.
Which, if you watch our videos on the
Jesuits, you understand why that is so
significant when we look at Bible
prophecy. They they're all following the
plan. They're all following the plan.
Too. And and and
it's funny that they don't hide it.
Right? It's like all there.
Well, they're trying to, but they're
trying not to. They're like they're
playing chess. It's it's like
not a puzzle Yeah. that you have to put
pieces together because they write it
plainly how they want to do it. But,
somehow you're still
still it's like most people won't see
it. Mhm. You know, because you won't you
won't to you it won't matter if you are
actually not grounded, if you're not
um
if you're not studying your Bible, and
you won't you don't know what prophecy
uh is going to happen or what's going to
happen in the end of the times. You read
all this stuff that they're planning and
to you it doesn't really matter.
You know, as long as we're united, as
long as we're loving each other it's all
good, it's all peace, it's all love.
Yeah, but, you know, it all comes with a
purpose. You know, they all say, "Oh,
yeah, we want religious. We want
everyone to religion is is, you know uh
one world religion, but it's the one
world religion that will benefit them.
Mhm.
Really.
And we can see here from Revelation
that, you know, we know what is the end
of all this. It's not going to be
pretty. Yeah. And that's why it matters
so much because we know the end right
now because it was written before. Yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah, so we are sharing this with you
guys out of love. If you haven't watched
our video on what is the Antichrist
power, what is the mark of the beast, go
watch it for yourself. I'm telling you
this is really really important stuff.
The Bible the the the Revelation 1:1
says, "The Revelation of Jesus Christ."
There are people who say that Revelation
is a closed book. But, that's not what
the scriptures say.
The scriptures talk about you should
read this book. If this is about the the
Revelation of Jesus Christ then the
Revelation, the book of Revelation, is
as important to read as the Gospels
because all of those in fact the whole
Bible is about Jesus.
But, for those who are very keen on the
Gospels, which I love as well. I love
everything about the Bible. Revelation
is something that should be studied. And
if you want to learn more about how to
study the Book of Revelation or anything
in the Bible, anything related to
prophecy, we have a free online Bible
school on
available for you. So, you can click the
link in the description below and go
there. And it's all scripture compared
with scripture as the Bible says how we
should study the Bible. Compare
scripture with scripture. Don't
interpret it from a human point of view.
Interpret it the way God wants us to
interpret it using his word. Guys, thank
you so much for watching. If you want to
support the kind of work that we do and
our ministry, please go to lls.tv/give.
Or you can go to patreon.com/little
light studios. Also, Keith's wearing a
pretty awesome hoodie actually referring
to Jesus being our solid rock from
Isaiah. And I'm wearing one that says
love keeps no record of wrongs. So,
we've got a Christian merch company
called Lightwear. You can get your own
t-shirt at lightwear.shop and spread the
word, spread God's love, spread his
word, and support the ministry at the
same time. Also, make sure you hit
subscribe, leave a comment below to tell
us what you think of this episode, and
share it with your friends. And make
sure
If you like our videos, it actually gets
the videos out in the algorithm more.
So, please do that. I think that's a
wrap for today. We'll see you guys next
week.